accompagnement financement expertise
réseau et immobilier d'entreprise les
acteurs de la création d'entreprise au
forum je crée ma boîte
un événement organisé par saint quentin
en yvelines et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines objectif
conseiller et orienter les entrepreneurs
dans leurs démarches de création
la plupart du temps les porteurs de
projets viennent en disant j'ai une idée
je veux savoir la meilleure forme
juridique kim qui me convient et les
aides que je peux avoir
donc mon rôle c'est dans un premier
temps c'est dire c'est bien de vous
poser ces questions-là
mais ce n'est pas que ça avant il faut
poser votre projet par écrit pour savoir
si votre projet est bien parmi les
visiteurs cédric leroy son projet créer
une société de conseil dans le domaine
du sport avec pour cible le marché
indien j'étais un petit peu perdues pour
être tout à fait franc avec vous il ya
énormément de statut de société qui
existe j'ai pris des renseignements un
petit peu sur internet mais je me suis
vite rendu compte qu'il y avait une
limite à tout ça et que c'était
important de pouvoir échanger avec des
personnes physiques et a pris justement
qui avait un service international au
niveau de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie sauf que je ne savais pas du
tout donc j'ai fait une prise de rendez
vous et ils m'accompagnent auront
ensuite sur justement le choix de
on statut d'entreprise de son côté
sybille capelle veut développer une
plateforme de recrutement
une démarche après plusieurs années
passées en entreprise demandeurs
d'emploi elles se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat qui est un réseau qui
est très très bien ficelé et qui aide
grandement les créateurs d'entreprise dd
l'embryon l'idée donc c'est plutôt sympa
statut juridique protection sociale
étude de marché des thèmes abordés dans
ses ateliers à l'intérieur du ski cube
c'est des ateliers de 45 minutes
généralement il ya une demi-heure en
fait d'intervention du formateur de
l'expert de la thématique et derrière il
ya toujours 15 minutes d'échangés avec
les participants au premier trimestre
2010 9 plus de 5200 entreprises ont été
créées dans les yvelines